dave ramsey i think you are wrong and
let me tell you why
so dave ramsey
is saying he doesn't think real estate
is going to take a hit
he thinks real estate's going to be
maybe a minor little hit but not a big
hit which by the way he may be right
however there's one data point you have
to look at whether real estate's going
to take a hit or not because that's
where his argument is his argument is
how is real estate going to take a hit
if inventory isn't there well
if inventory isn't there guess who's
right
dave ramsey is right
why here's why because say i'm a realtor
and adam is looking to buy a million
dollar house okay and he specifically
wants to buy this house in a community
that is close to the school because he
wants his cats and his kids to go to a
nice private school
but the challenge is the best there is
only one there's only two million dollar
homes in the market
one of them doesn't have a swimming pool
the other does have a swimming pool he
wants a swimming pool one is four
bedroom the other one is three bedroom
he needs four bedrooms so i go there and
i say adam i don't think we're gonna
make a million dollar offer here because
you're not gonna get it he says what do
you mean i said if you try to negotiate
hard here you're going to lose because
they're going to get 50 offers i say we
go strong what are you talking about i
say we go with an offer of 1.15 pat it's
a million dollar listing i say you offer
1.1 1.15 if you really want this thing
because if you don't it's going to go
cash cash is going to come at 1.2 so
adam's now panicking and by the way my
argument as a realtor in that situation
guess who's right i'm right in that
situation and adam sits there and says
what damn this guy's right why because
he goes on realtor every day and nothing
new is popping up yes or no when you're
looking at houses right so adam says
okay pat i'm not going to make an offer
1.15 but i'll make an offer for what a
million 85. okay great he puts the offer
for a million 85 we send it in
their realtor comes back saying we got
47 offers the biggest one is 1.11 this
is your last chance what do you want to
do i tell adam adam if you don't get
this there's probably not going to be
anything for another year or two adam
comes back and says let's make that
offer 1.16 he loses at 1.17 okay
today if inventory was 50 for the
million dollar house and 30 of them had
a swimming pool with four bedroom guess
what adam's now doing
i'm saying make an offer of 880. yeah
making off from ninth i'm not making a
million dollar offer there's 45 other
properties i can look at so here's
what dave ramsey says
the housing market is not crashing sorry
to end your fear porn party but the sky
is really not falling it's definitely
scary and some of the things going on
truly do suck but the sky is not falling
and the way he's explaining it is the
fact that the inventory
is not there now pull up the data i just
pulled uh sent to you from realtor.com
this is realtor.com article okay and it
shows
what's happened go up a little bit and
then zoom in go up go up go up go up to
the chart and then zoom in zoom in okay
check this out guys look at this go a
little bit out okay there you go watch
this
so active listing count the years you
see the colors 2017 18 19 20 21 22 22 is
at the bottom it's the yellow one do you
see that okay so
inventory active listing in january to
february it goes down
february to march pretty even
march to april about flat april to may
boom
may to june
boom
18.7 year-over-year
this data increasing is the scariest
thing for realtors and it's the best
thing for buyers so if this thing climbs
up dave ramsey has to apologize to his
fan base for getting this wrong and it's
going up if this thing goes down we will
give dave ramsey a shout out for getting
it right but it's that simple
folks if there's any data you want to
watch pay very very close attention to
this you know how you were going to
shops and you didn't see any rolexes for
sale
plenty of rolex's for sale right now
right now everybody's selling them so
you want to buy rolex they're everywhere
right and why why they think
they're everywhere they're selling
everything people are getting rid of
everything i mean listen wall street
journal story came up
pull up the wall street journal story
about uh
anyways tom i'll turn it over to you
give some thoughts on this on what i'm
saying yeah there are three things that
are out there driving this right now
that are all facts and by the way i love
it when you put the charts up there
because whenever i go toe-to-toe with
liberals i have a little phrase i like
uh-oh facts here they come well the
first thing you've done is the inventory
so what's making the inventory dave
ramsey is not liberal whatsoever just so
you talk about dave okay about the facts
here gotcha so the first element is that
right now
those people that partnered maybe you
and me adam we partnered we were trying
to do a couple house flips here in south
south florida guess what the party's
over what are we saying to each other
right now hey we don't have deep pockets
we're not like blackrock buying up
residential real estate everywhere guess
what we need to get out of this now
these the prices are flattening out
interest rates are going up we have to
get out we're putting inventory on
that's first second there is
unemployment that is starting to happen
in key areas that inventory is coming on
market and third the as soon as the
price is level all of the sidelines this
is the biggest group pat people that
were on the sidelines that was thinking
of selling a house and maybe moving or
retiring going a different area they've
been watching the prices go up and
remember when prices go up like stock
goes up i won't sell it today maybe
apple will be 1700 tomorrow i won't sell
at 1700 maybe apple will be 1800
tomorrow you know you get talked into
the next level agreed you know what i
mean pat the next one percent those
people that were on the sideline are
bringing inventory on the market right
now because they say the party's over
and i'm getting out all of that is
driving inventory and by the way
the normal number one thing that drives
inventory is job change it's forced
inventory and that that storm hasn't
even come ashore yet but if you want to
do the real estate market like a
hurricane map here in florida it's
coming all of this is driving inventory
and it it has to drive prices down so
ramsay and other people that are maybe
living in denial and thinking it's not
going to happen not going to be so bad
it's going to bottom out right here no
it's not we got another three-quarters
interest rate two weeks ago right here
come let's see interest rates and the
layoffs are gonna keep feeling it
talking fast so i could get it done
there's there's two camps here
choose your camp
choose your camp folks
there's the one camp
that's saying
nothing's wrong everything's gonna be
all right
the house prices are not going to drop
don't worry about it keep spending your
money keep living your opposite the same
exact way that's one camp the other camp
is
shit's about to hit the fan
real estate's going to drop inflation is
going to keep going up interest rates
are going to go up the next 12 18 24
months are going to be ugly but it's
going to be fine it's not the end of the
world will come out of this in the next
two three four five years and then
everybody goes back to business as usual
here's the key about these two different
camps whichever camp you choose you just
hope you're part of the right camp in
two years okay because if you're part of
the wrong camp in two years you are not
gonna come out of this thing better than
you were prior to this camp so to the
dave ramsey camp look go to the other
part about the savings these are a
couple things folks have to pay close
attention to
this is a wsj story americans tap
pandemic savings to cope with inflation
okay what happens when people start
tapping into their savings because
inflation they run out of savings and
then after they run out of savings what
do they do they start selling things
that they have and when they start
selling things that they have
what happens when a seller is selling
something and he has to use that thing
that he's selling to pay the mortgage
next friday uh and you tell him i'll
wait two weeks and he says no no no but
what if we do a deal right now no no no
i'll buy it in two weeks no no right now
you can screw them listen not screw them
it's not screwing it's called being
irresponsible
i've been irresponsible without why i
was forced to sell stuff because i
desperately needed money and a person
that was responsible guess what
that credit goes to the person that was
responsible there's nothing wrong with
the guys that hey when everybody else
was partying you were saving money then
when the time comes like this this is
the time when you get to buy things for
sale while everybody else was buying 700
bottles and you were not
that's just there's oh that's that's all
there is to it works in your 20s 30s 40s
when that age starts with four man that
stuff kind of changes a little bit so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]